if you're looking for the perfect gift
this holiday look no further than
oprah's favorite thing yep gayle curates
here it is that's right and gail curates
the list with oprah and you're going to
show us one thing that's perfect for
serving to all your hungry family
members and friends what is it because
it's no secret you know this i don't
know how to cook
i think there are a lot of people like
this my children will have no memories
of you know when mom used to make fill
in the blank i have nothing like that so
here's the thing this is called the fab
fat white corn and listen to this
truffle souffle
i know don't you love a truffle created
by a texas caterer the souffle arrives
pre-made and frozen all you have to do
is thought and bake it it features fresh
white corn black truffle oil available
for purchase in the dish we like this
orange
ramekin yeah it comes in this it comes
really is that what this is called a
ramekin a ramekin yeah okay so it comes
in this ramekin
or it comes as a two pack refill if you
already have the ramekin
it's funny i just call it the white
casserole dish but okay the ramekin it
serves eight and it's 112 dollars so
what i like to do is get this
and then go to sweet green i like sweet
green or harvest bowl
get a little salad so you have a souffle
and a salad i'm dying for you to taste
it okay here we go
oh no it's amazing
it's amazing
yeah
oh wow this is amazing
amazing
the
creaminess it almost has like a cottage
it's creamy and custardy and it has but
it also has a little crunch on top
fluffy
oh it also has a question amazing
and it could serve at least four people
this is at least four people and and it
is very pretty that's how it looks when
it comes out of the oven
i think that's what we call a hot tip
hot doop
be sure to check out the rest of oprah's
favorite things on oprah daily
one of my favorite sites the word daily
i think promises
it delivers the daily word is the
smartest thing ever it's like get on the
feeder we're going to be right here
oprah's a big quote girl yeah so we
always that's how we always start the
site i love quotes you know andy cohen
just came out with a book um a hunt like
a 365 days i saw him on your show yeah
and it's a really great book it's really
fun i saw him and did you know his
favorite color is yellow too did you
know that i did not my favorite color is
yellow so is drew's that's why it makes
me happy when i come in and see all you
guys with your yellow faces
[Applause]
wow
i'm gonna get i'm gonna get you that
book because it's a nice little you know
like that get the i'm on it
i just saw andy because i was doing
something with saturday night live we're
doing something with lauren michaels oh
wow so they let us come backstage to for
the for the show this past week taylor
swift was was a guest i don't know if
you guys have seen taylor's new new
thing the red version oh yeah
we talked about it
it's so good
so she did her 10-minute song but the
point i was making andy was there
i knew i was going somewhere with this
story i know you're like what is she
talking about andy was there and so we
were talking about his book he was
telling me about his book now i have a
question because we talked about this on
the news the other day
like hal has no fury like a taylor
scorned
how do you feel about like that you know
she she will she will take you to task
if you uh you know
treat her wrong
how do i feel about it doesn't bother me
it doesn't bother me i think listen
and she never says who it's about
even though everybody knows
she never says who it's about
i it doesn't bother me so much i you
know sometimes feel sorry for the person
yeah who's on the other side of that
but i think that's how she expresses
herself i'm a big i love taylor's music
i love how she writes i love it but i
know people say it's not so nice i've
heard that um yeah yeah i think it's
tough you know for the person but i also
agree that everyone was so excited to
hear adele's new album
and that's very personal and that's very
personal i loved what she said
so much about her divorce to your bestie
because
that's exactly what i've been trying to
convey and she did it so succinctly and
not blaming anybody beautifully she's
not blaming anyone i would never air
the dirty laundry or tell anybody
anything public about what went on you
know behind closed doors with me and my
kids dad it just unfortunately didn't
work and it was the most devastating
thing i've ever gone through in my life
she said it was embarrassing she never
had a family she had this idea of a
nuclear family
i literally sat there on her every word
going
let's i've been there and then she felt
bad that she let herself down and i
thought her honesty and her candor
i thought was really admirable and i
think will help a lot of people well i
really appreciated it um i did too and i
think when that divorce death of a dream
occurs
it takes you however long it takes you
to heal but there's no
misstep in putting the kids first and
figuring out how to co-parent from day
one i'm also divorced and been to
several marital counselors and one
marital counselor said something i
thought was really profound to me he
said
you have to love your children more than
you are disappointed and i had an issue
with monogamy monogamy in my marriage i
think it's better to be married to
someone who believes in monogamy
i think that that's actually a good
thing
but
you know so of course i was very angry i
was very hurt and somebody would say
how are you and i go you know what he
did to me and then i'd see people's eyes
like oh my god i was just saying how are
you
then you realize nobody cares
nobody wants to hear all of that and at
the end of the day the children love
their father the
children love their father the father
loves their children and you have to put
your children first and figure out we
are going to make this work together so
today you know we've just had as we sit
here today we've had our first
grandchild i wish him well i have no ill
will against him whatsoever but for me
it was a process to get there because
you are so angry and you are so hurt but
at the end of the day
i i it pains me when i see women or men
use their children as weapons
to put them in the middle because it's
just not fair to the children it's just
not i somehow i don't care what he or
she did you've got to i mean that
sincerely it doesn't matter what they
did
short of abuse i'm not talking about
abuse
i am not talking about abuse of course
yes but short of that it doesn't matter
what happened between the two of you the
most important thing is that your
children come out
happy healthy and whole and you all can
do that together and don't involve the
children listen i never said anything
disparaging about their dad to their
children i would just tell my friends
and my mom but i would never involve the
children because you you don't dr phil
says this all the time you don't involve
children in grown-up issues and i really
do believe that i agree i really do
believe that let them be children yes
yes which is why i'm really protective
of mine i'm like just be children let's
stay off social media not they can see
it but i don't put them on mine i'm
going to carry this ramekin with me you
can take the ramekin all right everybody
thank you so much for joining in this
conversation and
thank you thank you thank you
[Music]
you